A few days ago, I flew in from Chicago.
I love it there.
Chicago has it all.
Oh, thank you.
Great food, incredible skyline
and architecture
and the kindest Midwestern folks
you'll ever meet.
Diversity of people
and culture, second to none.
Millions of people move
to cities like Chicago each year
to pursue their life's
dreams and passions.
I know I did.
And that's because cities are booming
marketplaces of people and companies,
of products and materials
and something not so great:
waste and greenhouse gas emissions.
According to a 2022 World Bank report,
our beloved communities
could be responsible
for 25 gigatons of carbon emissions
and a ton and ton of waste.
But what does this mean
for your community?
Think about that building being torn down,
maybe on the corner
next to your office or your home
and all the wood and concrete and steel
or the office equipment or computers
or furniture being tossed out,
dumped in a landfill,
often near the homes
of our low-income neighbors.
In the United States,
40 percent of landfill contain materials
from the construction
and demolition of buildings.
This is our linear economy.
It's bad for our climate,
it's bad for our health,
and it's a missed economic opportunity.
But we can turn this line into a circle.
Many connected circles, in fact,
where every a physical resource
finds another use and another life,
driving down greenhouse gas emissions
from new manufacturing,
shrinking harmful landfill
and creating a lot of jobs.
This disconnected linear economy
becomes a circular one
when we transform our concept of ownership
into a system where every person
and every business
has access to the things
others no longer find useful.
Wood from that building being torn down
could be a dining room table.
Bricks could be concrete again
and furniture can be rehabbed
and resold to an up-and-coming start-up.
Now my circular economy journey
started on a pretty small scale.
I was a neuroscientist in a lab
at Northwestern University.
At that time, in my lab,
there were hundreds
if not thousands of biological tools
and things like microscopes,
that were going completely unused.
In fact, research budgets
were tight then and actually now,
but still, these things
sat around collecting dust.
No one even knew they existed.
So I loaded up a push cart,
rolled it around my floor
with these items,
visited my colleagues,
shared what we no longer needed
and they might be able to.
Rheaply, the company I founded and run,
helps organizations identify
and catalog the things they own,
reuse them internally when they can
and distribute them to other
organizations when they cannot.
It's like a high-tech, scaled-up version
of me with the push cart at Northwestern,
but with hundreds of organizations,
from technology to manufacturing leaders,
and millions of items
available for ale and donation --
all cataloged on a digital platform,
stretching across partners
in a local area, a city or state,
creating connected networks of reuse.
Rheaply helps organizations reuse
things like building materials
and IT and industrial
equipment and furniture.
But companies like Goodr or Olio
help reduce food waste
by connecting surplus food
to people who are hungry.
And companies like Queen of Raw
and Trove and Recurate
create circular loops for textiles,
apparel and other branded goods.
Let's take a look
at how it works for furniture.
An investment bank in New York City
had about 2,000 premium office chairs
that they no longer could use.
When they hired us,
we sent in a team to inventory
that furniture on that floor.
We photographed it, we tagged it
and we uploaded it to the system.
When it was determined that these items
could no longer be useful internally,
a notification was sent out through
our platform to all of our partners,
hundreds of them.
I'm happy to report that all
of these chairs found new homes
in a local university,
a community housing organization
and a local refurbishment company.
Thank you.
(Applause)
In total, about 68,000 pounds
of potential waste
was diverted from landfill,
and about 100,000 dollars of value
was recaptured and shared
with these organizations.
Not to mention the carbon savings.
Making one of these office chairs,
which weighs about 55 pounds,
releases 245 pounds of carbon
emissions into the atmosphere.
Now, this is just a small set
of furniture on one floor
in one building of one bank
in New York City.
Think of all the other office equipment
and IT infrastructure
that we could be reusing.
In this specific case,
the bank paid us as a part of meeting
their sustainability goals,
but the chairs were mostly donated.
Sometimes furniture or equipment
or materials can be resold
even for a 50-plus percent discount.
Sometimes refurbished
and sometimes split into parts
and used by industrial recycler.
OK.
So we know how to create
a circular economy
with a microscope on a pushcart
like me at Northwestern.
And we know how to do so
inside and outside of a building
with either its building materials
or things like IT infrastructure
on a digital platform like Rheaply.
But how do we get to the scale of a city?
And why?
Well, cities occupy about three percent
of global land mass
but house over 50 percent
of the global population,
which commands over 75 percent
of all global resources.
Cities are perfect, tractable fronts
for us to drive down
greenhouse gas emissions
and create a lot of jobs
by building local circular economies.
Now to transition any city's linear
economy to a circular one,
we're going to, at the very least,
have to do three things.
First, we have to build
a digital infrastructure
to connect every citizen
and every company
to everything in their city.
Next, we're going to have to build
the operational infrastructure
to make reuse and recycling
and remanufacturing easy
and universally acceptable.
Next, we're going to have to incentivize
every person and business
to participate in their
local circular economy.
As you might expect from a person like me,
technology is at the heart
of any circular city.
So at the very first step,
we have to provide
universal access to the internet.
But then very quickly after,
we have to create local marketplaces,
collections of digital platforms
where anything from toys
to building materials can be posted,
found, collected and exchanged.
Now, this is already happening
on platforms like Craigslist
and Facebook and the Buy Nothing Project,
but we have to go much bigger and expand
into many more product categories.
In fact, we’re going
to have to like, Google Map
all the industrial equipment
to office furniture in our cities.
Because in a circular city,
we actually have to know where things are.
But if we can do this,
we create a second and third life
for every physical resource,
increasing its lifetime value
and delaying its journey to the landfill.
But it's not just about reusing things.
If we're going to sustain
this connected flow
of circular products and materials,
we're going to have to build
the operational capacity
in recycling, remanufacturing and reuse.
And we're going to need things
like repair shops
and training programs
like Arne Duncan’s Chicago CRED,
where they're upskilling at-risk youth
on the South Side of Chicago.
Or the circular construction laboratory
at Cornell University,
where they're training the next generation
of eco-conscious architects.
With greater capacity,
we can reduce the green premium
or cost associated
with reuse and recycling.
And we're going to need more local hubs
like the Lifecycle Building
Center in Atlanta,
where building materials can be donated
and reused in the community.
And we’re going to need
more refurbishment companies
like The Furniture X-Change in New Jersey
or Envirotech in Ontario,
where they take old furniture
and make something modern and appealing.
And of course, we're going to need more
local shipping and delivery companies.
Last but very importantly,
we're going to have to match these digital
and operational infrastructure investments
with smart public policy
that incentivizes participation
in a circular economic model.
In San Francisco,
the Department of Environment
has adopted ordinances
and solutions that drive
local circularity and reuse.
Last November,
Massachusetts made it illegal
to throw out textiles,
becoming the very first state to do so.
They've even launched a website
that maps out all the recycling outlets
where these materials can be discarded.
And in San Antonio,
one of my personal favorites,
you don't pay property taxes
for five years
if you rehab a building
in a local historic district.
Now, here's where it's exciting
for public policymakers.
A circular city could be
a thriving economy.
Businesses in these
city-based circular economies
are going to need large local workforces
to update internet infrastructure,
to repair or remanufacture goods
or just to resell and drive
things across town.
Now these ideas
are getting a lot of traction.
Last year, Rheaply,
with many other organizations,
formed the Circular City Coalition
led by Pyxera Global.
The Coalition's purpose
is to help any city transition
from linear to circular,
while making sure it benefits everyone
in the community equally.
And here's where I get excited,
and I think you all should, too.
If we can summon the focus and energy
to build just 1,000
of these circular cities by 2040,
we'll drive down global greenhouse
gas emissions by more than 60 percent
and get back on track
to meeting the targets
set out in the Paris Accords.
Yes.
(Applause)
We've got to do it.
I'm a city boy from Chicago.
And I know you love your city, too.
Cities are ground zero in the fight
against global climate change.
And in that fight, we're all neighbors,
not competitors, not strangers.
We need each other
in whatever city or town we reside in.
And if we can all just participate
in making our cities circular,
sharing resources locally
when we no longer need them,
a concept that simple,
then a net-zero future is possible.
Thank you.
Thank you, TED.
(Applause)